Here are the two original equations and let's try graphing them. The first
equation is already in slope-intercept form, so I won't do anything with it. For
the second equation, I'll change it into slope-intercept form. First, I subtract
4 x from both sides, then I divide each term by negative 2. This is where want
to be careful. I get positive 1y here, positive 2x here. And negative 3 for my
constant. The y intercept is negative 2 for the purple graph and the slope is
positive 2 over 1. For the green graph, the y intercept is negative 3 and our
slope is 2. Notice that the slopes are the same, so we have parallel lines.
Parallel lines will never intersect. So, we know that there can't be a solution
here. Whenever we solve an equation and get a statement like 4 equals 6, we know
there can't be a solution. The lines must parallel, just like in this case.